today we're reviewing the r-tx 2060 with
additional tests on if an RTX 2060 has
enough performance to really run games
with ray tracing basically battlefield
at this point and that's on the TU 106
GPU we have a separate teardown going
live showing the even more insane cooler
assembly of the RT x 2060 over the 20 80
series besting the previous complexity
of the already insane twenty eighty
series today's focus however will be on
performance in gaming thermals RT x
performance power consumption and
acoustics for the Founders Edition and
Vidya RT X 2060 before that this video
is brought to you by Thermaltake score
p3 case the core p3 is one of the most
unique cases on the market it can serve
as an open-air standing chassis a test
bench in vertical or horizontal
orientation or as a wall mounted
showcase PC the core p3 now comes with a
5 millimeter thick tempered glass panel
for its side but keeps the front top and
back open for air the core p3
versatility as a display piece test
bench or standard desktop is reinforced
by its price of roughly 110 dollars on
Amazon you can learn more at the link in
the description below we're gonna get
right into this one today because CES is
now when the video goes live and so
everything's a mess including having
still our new copper Mule mugs with
thermal conductivity for copper on them
on the table so that the 2060 is $350
that's first they need to know there's
no more special founders Edition price
it's just 350 flat and that is for the
the the founders Edition and for partner
model baseline MSRP partners can go over
that you'll see a lot of cards for 400
but 350 prices will actually exist for
some of the cards just like the 27 tees
have there's low on models like the EVGA
black for 500 so that's what you need to
know there's still the a designation for
the special GPU thins the higher
frequency ones which we showed
previously that still exists with the
2060 as far as we know the 2060 f.e is
an ace Q it has been a bit higher than
some of the ultra cheap cards which we
might see later
so other prices for cards just to give
our own perspective the 1060 these days
about
ten dollars us for a 6-ski by model if
you can find it some of the cards are
more like 240-250 depend on where you
look which was baseline MSRP but we do
see them more regularly than not for 210
or so these days the artists 590 is
about 250 to 270 some at 280 but on
average you'll see them 260 or to 74 590
which does generally outperform a 1060
but not always GTA is an example of what
it doesn't but most the time it does the
r-tx 20 7500 bucks baseline 550 on
average and then the 2060 falls in
between now for performance we're gonna
do the content in this order so there's
games for DirectX 12 and DirectX 11
first then we'll talk RT X in
battlefield 5
we'll talk thermals extensively we'll
talk nose and we'll talk power
consumption and overclocking and then
we'll give you the wrap-up at the end
Sniper Elite 4 is our first text this
one was chosen because of its well
implemented low-level API access and
bypass to the normal abstraction layers
presented by both rappers and dx11
we'll start with our 4k test for a
baseline with the most data to compare
against at 4k Sniper Elite 4 has the
stock r-tx 2016 56 FPS average with lows
at well timed at 50 fps and 49 fps 1%
and 0.1% low respectively this is
indicative of consistent frame time
performance something we'll look at next
overclocking the RIT X 2060 to a 160
megahertz offset because 175 was
unstable in this game landed it at 61
FPS average a gain of approximately
eight point nine percent not bad the
EVGA r-tx 2070 low-end model for
perspective performs at 64 FPS average
which is only 4% ahead of the
overclocked r-tx 2060 granted
overclocked in the 2070 furthers its
lead to 70 FPS average but the point is
that the 2060 is nearly achieving 2070
levels of performance when the former is
overclocked the RX 590 ends up at about
43 FPS average when stock allowing the
2060 elite of about 31 percent over the
590 it also has a price difference but
we'll talk about that in the conclusion
the positioning of the 2060 puts Vega 64
just barely ahead of it and functionally
tied with the 2060 overclocked the 1070
TI also equates 2060 levels of
performance with Vega 56
distant when stock generationally the
r-tx 2060 outperforms the gtx 1066
gigabyte gaming x and is 37 FPS average
by 52% that's a massive lead and some of
that is because of the twenty-sixth ease
improved capabilities with asynchronous
command queuing type really 4 also
benefits from the boosted memory
bandwidth on the 2060
although the 50% increase in lanes on
the vectors further helps over the gtx
960 SSC 4k perforins has improved
measurably from 20 FPS average 256 FPS
average higher resolution throughput has
seen heavy focus over the past two
generations well look at frame time
performance next as a reminder frame
time charts are the most representative
look at real experience displaying a
frame to frame interval for every
instance of gameplay this helps us look
at data that would get averaged out in
bar charts and best illustrates
performance for each individual frame
present lower is better but more
consistent is more important than lower
starting with a plot of the gtx 1066
gigabyte gaming x from last generation
we see a line plot that sits between 25
and 32 milliseconds with overall frames
of frame pacing deviating no greater
than 1 to 2 milliseconds per frame the
frame rate isn't that good as we saw in
the previous chart but the frame time
consistency is about as good as it gets
lowering resolution resolves the frame
rate issue but frame time consistency is
the more difficult aspect to get correct
and this one already got it correct the
RX 590 plots next show an improved frame
rate by way of a 20 to 27 millisecond
frame time average also nearing peak
consistency the gtx 1070 plots better
frame rate than both of these nearing 20
milliseconds average and is the best
performer up until we plot the our TX
2060 the 2060 s sits between 15 and 20
milliseconds on average with sixteen
point six 67 milliseconds representing a
60 FPS throughput if you had sixteen
point six six seven across the entire
distribution the 2060 like the previous
cards has overall excellent frame time
consistency and would present minimal
hitching or stuttering in this title
1080p should be more interesting from a
generational scaling standpoint the our
TX 2060 ends up at 151 FPS average stock
which scales 46 percent over the
1066 gigabytes stock card or 165 percent
over the gtx 960 SSC the 1060 scaled 82%
over the gtx 960 SSC for perspective and
the difference is that the price has
moved with the RT x 2060 whereas the
pricing of the 960 and then 1060 we're
pretty similar at launch the 960 s
launch price was about 200 to 240
dollars to banana partner models with a
10 60 at about 240 to 250 and the 20 60
at $350 F 1 2018 give us a look at a
well built the x11 title at 4k F 1 2018
places the RT x26 TF e at 54 FPS average
just ahead of the vega 56 red dragon and
the gtx 980ti hybrid from two
generations ago the overclocked r-tx
2060 with a plus 175 core offset ends up
about tied with the stock RT x 2070 but
note that this core offset is difficult
to sustain without a lot of testing and
good cooling the 27 t of course outpaces
the 2060 when overclocked maintaining a
lead at 68 FPS average and of 14% when
both are overclocked versus overclocked
versus the stock gtx 1060 from the last
generation the 2060 stock card maintains
a 59 percent improvement the gtx 960
isn't on this chart due to limited
ability to run 4k and the RX 590 ends up
at 38 FPS average nearer the gtx 1070
than the 2060 at 1440p the r-tx 2060
ends up at 93 FPS average stock posting
excellent 1440p performance and
relatively playable 4k performance which
is important to note but between the two
1440p of course looks better this is
similar to the gtx 1070 TI the to being
imperceptibly different and just behind
vega 64 versus the gtx 1060 the 2060
posts a gain of 62% which is more than
what we saw at 4k the 2060 leads the 960
SSC by 123 percent
finally an overclock on the 2060 gets it
to nearing error margins of the RT x
2070 stock cards 102 FPS average running
1080p instead we need to pay attention
to the scaling gaps between the X X 60
generation GPUs the RT X 2060 place is
at 120 FPS average which
the GTX 960 gaming addicts by 61% within
margin of error of our last distance
measured the 2060 leads the 960 by 167
percent down marginally from the lead at
a higher resolution for reference making
56 runs 115 FPS average which is
imperceptibly different from the 1070 TI
and nearing 2060 performance the RX 590
is far behind at 82 FPS average far cry
5 uses the Ubisoft dunia engine and as
our next benchmark stressing the
geometry pipeline and putting load on
the cards by way of screen space
reflections and geometric complexity
with longer draw distances running 4k
the RT X 2060 ends up at 41 FPS average
dropping settings would allow this to be
a bit more playable of course and
increased frame rate but it may make
more sense to instead go down to 1440p
either way scaling positions this is
again functionally equivalent to the
1070 TI it's within margin of error and
Vega 56 the 2070 is ahead by a bit but
both cards are having trouble with this
workload at 4k 1440p shows the same
positioning 20 60 places with an error
of the 1070 ti it's led by Vega 64 but
is now led more significantly by the
2070 which holds a lead of 12%
overclocked in the 2060 pushes it to 82
FPS average are roughly tied to the
stock 2070 Vega 56 is outside of
perceptible differences versus the 2060
with the RX v 9d trailing notably behind
at 55 FPS average for perspective the
gtx 960 is at the bottom of the chart at
1080p the 2060 ends up over 100 FPS
average when stock falling between the
1070 Ti and Vega 64 cards not distant
from the gtx 1080 FTW generational
improvement versus the stock 10 60s 73
FPS average post a 47% lead not as big
as we've seen elsewhere but still a
tremendous leap the gtx 960 SSC operated
44 FPS average in the same test
demonstrating how far we've come by
allowing the 2060 to poll a 144 percent
lead again that's not quite as large a
lead as an other tests and helps
illustrate that the 2060s biggest
improvements over maxwell would be in
high resolution performance shadow of
the Tomb Raider uses a modified crystal
engine and should eventually get some
r-tx implementation but for today we're
testing just with high settings and TAA
across
all these resolutions 1080 1440 and 4k
we just say well they a and some SLI
testing but those aren't relevant for
this comparison the rgx 2060 ends up at
37 FPS average and 4k testing between
vega 56 and the GTX 980 overclocked into
2060 pushes it to 40 FPS average so it's
still struggling we'll need more than
just a settings drop to get reasonable
framerate out of this game as evidenced
by the 20 70s baseline performance of 41
FPS average right near the overclocked
to 2060 let's drop to 1440p at 1440p the
r-tx 2060 runs a 68 FPS average now
playable and maintains a 1% in 0.1
percent low performance also nearing 60
this kind of frame time consistency
tightness is indicative of an overall
smooth frame rate with no stutters
interval to interval the 2060 leads the
1066 gigabytes 41 FPS average by 65
percent further leading the 960 SSC by 1
so d 9 percent consistent with previous
games the RX 5 90 runs closer to the gtx
1070 with the RT x 20 70 stock card
being tied by the overclocked RTS 2060
this makes a compelling argument for
buying a cheaper 2060 an overclocked
unit in order to achieve 2070
performance at least in rasterization
just for reference in this chart we also
included the XC ultra 2070 data we'd
been pulling it for chart length reasons
and the previous ones but it clearly
illustrates that higher in 2070 s will
outperform the cheaper model and if we
technically have a bit more data here we
have GTA data we have some or 1080p data
but we'll leave that to the article and
link it below if you want that and
instead move on to something different
which is battlefield 5 RT X testing this
will teach us something new whereas GTA
is mostly a repeat of the previous
benchmarks in terms of scaling with
battlefield 5 the RT X 2060 tested in
single-player
with DX are off on low and on ultra is
what you're looking at now no this is
this is after the recent performance
improving patch so BF 5 is at peak
performance here with DX are fully
disable to be measured at 104 FPS
average using ultra settings across
multiple test passes with a frame
buffering disabled and all
post-processing in the basic tab
disabled as well like chromatic
aberration or lens distortion frame time
is posted 61 FPS 1% and 56 FPS gyro
407th which is actually not the best
we looked at frame time data and it
oscillates a bit between eight
milliseconds and twelve milliseconds now
that gap isn't big enough to really see
or observe as a human but it's getting
there it's about 812 milliseconds of the
perceptual range for most humans looking
at frame to frame intervals anyway we'll
look into that more later perhaps after
CES but it wasn't the most consistent
run we've seen yet and that's why
there's loes or not as high as the
average DXR on low puts us at 66 FPS
average with DXR on ultra drooping to 55
FPS allowing 0.1% to hit 33 FPS average
so we'll give the 2060 credit where it's
due it's able to play this game at 1080p
and roughly 60 FPS with ray-tracing
fully enabled or well partially enabled
anyway it does lose about 40 percent of
its performance in doing so but it can
do it so it'd be a question of do you
want to play at 1440p Ultra with no rate
racing or 1080p ultra no ray-tracing at
100-plus fps or do you want to tank your
FPS go down to 1080p and take the
ray-tracing and it's sort of subjective
but as people who have seen all these
options in person we can tell you that
generally speaking killing the rate
racing on this card and instead going
for the higher frame rate in this
particular game does feel a bit better
but it's going to detent depend on the
game like if it's a more in-depth RPG or
something where you want that immersion
so we'll talk about that if it ever
happens let's get into thermals for this
we disassembled the r-tx 20 60 and
attached thermocouples to the PCB
components we have some b-roll of the
disassembly process that we can show
it's an insane amount of effort to take
this card apart and videos use of hot
glue to hold in fan cables and seven
screws to hold in that set that same fan
cable really don't make sense it's just
it's crazy what they did to assemble
this thing but the rest of the heat sink
fan assembly is equally crazy and you
can watch our teardown video coming up
shortly for that if you haven't already
seen it the PCB is the same as an RT X
27 T PCB it's just the cooler has been
actually changed in the ecent amount the
PCB has been simplified though some
they've removed memory modules of course
but we already know the hot spot MOSFETs
from the 27 t PCB so
thermocouples on those starting first
with fur mark for torture thermals we
measured the stock GPU temperature as 68
degrees Celsius throughout the test
ambient was 22 degrees plus or minus one
for our regulars this isn't presented
this time as delta T over ambient it's
just 68 degrees straight setting the fan
noise to 40 DBA to normalized noise
levels with our other tests we see GB
temperature fall to 64 degrees because
Nvidia's default fan profile leans up
more toward quiet than cool and so 40
DBA a reasonable noise level actually
brains a reduction in thermals which
isn't all that common MOSFET
temperatures end up at 78 degrees
Celsius for the stock card which is
within spec and reasonable or 73 degrees
for the 40 dB a variant on testing these
mosfet thermals are within spec and
doing fine overall there's really no
problem here not until you're 90 plus
degree isn't even that it's not really
catastrophic we won't bother plotting
this but for the curious the auto fan
speed it was 1700 rpm or about 45
percent forty DBA fan speeds are about
52 percent for the next chart we're
looking at 3dmark fire strike extreme
performance over a prolonged period the
point is to see how the core clock
behaves when under a gaming workload as
some clocks will bounce around more
heavily based on load first plotting the
temperature we see GPU core temperature
at 69 to 70 degrees on the Left axis
with MOSFET temperature at 76 degrees
also on the left axis the frequency cue
line comes in next starting initially at
nineteen thirty-five megahertz and
remember this is stock so it's a pretty
high frequency and dropping almost
immediately to eighteen seventy-five
megahertz once that steady state
frequency sustains at this level in a
nearly perfect line which is rare and
good the drop from nineteen thirty-five
megahertz is because GB core temperature
steadily rises from 30 degrees up to
where it lands driving down frequency
pursuant to boost behavior every couple
of degrees it matters for frequency
overall though and video is doing better
on this card than its previous designs
and that's because the TDP is lower
overall for the GPU core than the twenty
eighty series now TDP is not lower in
fact it's higher versus the ten series
but that's not really what we're looking
at here we'll look at that
moment as for noise levels we're
starting at a lower baseline of 32
percent or 1190 RPM with our TX 20 60
whereas some of the previous our TX
cards had a floor of 41 percent or 1525
rpm the our TX 2060 has the same
acoustic performance as the other our TX
coolers more or less but does plot idle
noise lower @ 31.4 DBA the average load
fan speed is about 1670 rpm and 22
degree ambient testing environments
putting fan speeds at around 37 DBA you
can expect it to be a bit higher maybe
39 to 40 in a hot case 100% loads put
the our TX 2060 at fifty eight point
seven DBA it's still louder than a good
aftermarket cooler but it's similar to
low-end coolers like the RT X 2070 black
by EVGA so this is just going to depend
on how much money you spend on the card
remember that decibels are logarithmic
so these increases are non-linear it's
it's not the same scale as you see with
other charts people tend to start
noticing noise changes for reference
with roughly every three DBA increase
where there abouts it's a bit of a human
perceptual difference there so that's
kind of up to you
finally from power consumption we're
looking at total system power draw with
a heavily controlled test bench all
voltages are controlled on the
motherboard ensuring no fluctuations
that would throw off measurements this
is not individual card draw but an
overtime plot of total system draw first
the our TX 2060 ends up at about 260
watts to 300 watts total system power
consumption occasionally spiking to 310
watts
the average sustained high is about 300
watts flat overclocked in the GPU pushes
the system to 360 peak but the average
sustained high for the overclocked
variants is closer to 320 watts with
that OC we applied the gtx 1060 game
index with an overclock which is about
240 watts total system power draw for
perspective so NVIDIA has gone up
generationally alongside its performance
in Greece it makes the performance gains
a little bit less impressive when you
put into perspective the required
additional power to do it now it's not a
lot of additional power compared to some
other cards we've seen in the market but
it is an increase and that takes away
some of the just how special it was to
see there's 50 plus percent gains
because it's not
really that directly comparable when you
have higher power consumption TDP was
previously 120 watts and is now 160
watts by Nvidia spec and power
consumption difference is noticeable
here this is still below the RX 5 90s
total system power consumption of 320 to
330 watts but not by much we won't plot
it since it make the chart too busy but
note also that the our TX 2070 is
roughly the same as the 2060 except it's
about 10 to 20 watts higher on average
maybe lining up at about 15 watts over
the whole test so overall the 2060 is
very close to the 2070 in power
consumption which makes sense given the
performance well put over clocks up in
on the screen briefly this is the chart
of our overclocked progression it's
about the same as the previous cards
overclocking did pretty well on our 2016
this will be your mileage may vary
scenarios where I mean if it's the
coolers not as good or if you just got a
worse bin then not much you can do about
it but that's what we got so it did
overclock well the biggest thing here
with overclocking is if you like the
2070 performance but you don't like the
price because you just don't have enough
money to justify it then the 2060 can
basically become a 20 70 it doesn't
scale linearly in every application but
it's pretty darn close and on average
2060 overclocked is about 2070 baseline
performance for a $500 2070 and of
course you can overclock of 20 72 but if
you just want 20 70 baseline you can buy
a 20 60 overclock it and pretty much get
it you'll be within a couple of percent
and it's a great way to save 150 or more
dollars so that's something to keep in
mind the RT performance might not scale
quite the same way we haven't looked
into that just yet but we do have some
baseline numbers to give you the rest of
it now as for the rest 2060 is a strong
1440p performer and of course has no
problem with 1080p 4k is is difficult to
do with those ultra and very high
settings but can be done with medium or
lower settings it's just kind of a
question of what do you want you know at
the frame rate and the higher quality or
do you want resolution and on average I
think most people generally would prefer
the higher quality to just straight high
resolution because you'll start noticing
the low quality at some point so 1440p
for sure no problem
4k
if the game is lightweight enough yeah
but probably not on average we wouldn't
buy it for 4k as a as as the main goal
of the GPU versus the RX 590 the RX 590
makes a lot of sense at two forty to
fifty to sixty dollars and especially
versus the ten sixty although the ten
sixty does have a few instances where
it's better so if you're only playing
GTA 5 just get the ten sixty but that
game is pretty old now people do play
more than one thing the 590 on average
is better overall the 590 versus the
2060 doesn't necessarily make sense as a
discussion point because it's a hundred
dollar price difference the 590 if you
really struggle to justify an extra
hundred bucks the 590 is fine it does
1080 it does 1440 mostly fine you can
tweak the settings you'll be okay the
2060 obviously different category of
price for performance and value it is
significantly improved over the previous
Nvidia r-tx launches Nvidia is feeling
much more confident about this product
in speaking with them than the inter
market perception than the previous
launches the 2080 as we all notice to
recap it really had no value over the
1080i it was RT cores and no games at
r-tx when it launched or for the 52 days
following and beyond that performance is
about 1080i performance so there was
there's no value there the 20 ATT I had
value because it's the best but that
only gets you so far when it's 1200 plus
dollars so those were much more rocky
there are difficult launches friend
video the 27 he started to turn things
around a little bit the 20 $7,500 cards
were decent enough value where you could
definitely justify it or argue it over
competition including primarily
competition for many videos previous
generation but once he got past 500
bucks it was a difficult argument
actually especially at 550 the value
just was was not that great so the 2060
furthers that and does correct things a
bit at 350 the value is pretty good
overall we would say if you are looking
for something that's strictly enthusiast
level for fun overclocking we would
still recommend Vega 56 it
is it's the most tweakable it's pretty
open you can do power plate tables mods
that you can't do it under the afford
any modifications of power limits and v
bios still pretty locked down but there
are things you can do to get around
stuff on AMD words you can't really with
anybody you're pretty locked in so if
you want just enthusiast level fun
genuinely just overclocking for fun then
vega 56 gets our vote still if you're
going for performance out of the box or
you kind of you might overclock for an
hour or two and then you never touch it
again for three years the 2060 is a good
option to consider it outperforms the
cards that are cheaper than it pretty
much well significantly in most
instances significant out performance
versus a ten sixty bit more power
consumption about 170 percent foreign so
up lifts your 2x plus your well yeah
hundred seventy percent more performance
than gtx 960 SSC for gigabyte card so if
you're nine hundred generation that's a
significant improvement seven hundred
generation significant improvement
versus RX 590 it's also holding a pretty
big lead on average so it's really vega
56 64 you're kind of looking at and
there was more or less flanked the 2060
it so it comes down to price and if you
can get a twenty 64 350 bucks it is a
pretty easy argument that that would be
a reasonable purchase or one of the
better purchases overclocking
enthusiasts options notwithstanding
where we'd still push you towards the
vega 56 because that's just it's a lot
of fun you can really unlock it do a lot
with it but it doesn't mean it's the
best performer or the best power
consumption especially when it's
overclocked so lots of stuff for you to
consider on the market these days that's
why these conclusions are getting longer
and it's more like for option a consider
these two option be consider these and
it's not just a flat-out by acts by why
because it is a complex market so 2016
for out-of-the-box performance $350
we're fine with it it is significantly
improved over the previous r-tx launches
so good for nvidia there and it can
actually somewhat surprisingly do r-tx
now that said battlefield fives rate
rates and implementation is pretty gross
it's really not well done we have a
whole video
I'm not going to go into it here you can
just search the channel for like
battlefield 5 RT X and our in-house 3d
artist an expert and all this stuff
helped me analyze it and did a great job
where we talked about the shortcomings
of RT acts and the good things that it
does so that's really not a compelling
reason to buy the 2060 the performance
is though and the rasterization
performance I will say the founders
Edition cooler is completely insane it
makes absolutely no sense
they made it worse than the 20 80 and 20
80 TI it's using now it's still using
glue but now in more places it uses glue
to hold the cable in place uses seven
screws to hold the fan cable in place
they've got soldered connectors wires
for the PCIe connector which are a a
risk of being broken if you need to
service the fans or replace the paste
for very common things to do overall and
they changed the screw sizes from the
previous ones they still have just as
many screws really the the if Nvidia
ever gets these back if you have one the
fan dies you send it back they're gonna
throw it away there's no way it's worth
the service technicians time that
they're paying him or her to repair a
card that you can barely even open so
it's just it is functionally impossible
for a novice to service and it is
difficult for an expert to service but
if you want to buy something for a
challenge I guess by 2060 and try to
take it apart so that's it for this one
thanks for watching subscribe for more
his always go destroyed I came is Nexus
net to pick up something like one of our
brand-new copper Mule mugs with the
thermal conductivity of copper written
on it because we think we're clever like
that where you go to patreon.com/scishow
cameras access it directly
stay tuned for CES thanks for watching
I'll see you all next time
[Music]